Minecon happened over the weekend and
with it came a trailer for minecraft
story mode and the announcement of
Minecraft Windows 10 edition in
minecraft story mode players will
control protagonist Jesse who along with
his pals are super into this legendary
order of the stone groups telltale
explains the order is the very best at
what they do warrior redstone engineer
creeper and rook attacks while at andak
on Jesse and his friends discovered
something is wrong something dreadful
Tara is unleashed and they must set out
on a journey to find the order of the
stone is there to save the world from
oblivion notable voice actors attached
to the project includes patton oswalt
ashley johnson from the last of us and
future armors Billy West minecraft story
mode is said to feature locations
including two never the farlands and the
end and we'll solo tell tells tried and
true episodic format peppered with
player choice minecraft Windows 10
edition was also announced and will be
free if you've already got the game on
PC and 10 bucks if you don't it's based
on the existing pocket version of the
game so don't expect every feature to
make an appearance at launch although
mojang have said they're aiming for
feature parity you'll be able to play
local and online multiplayer with other
pocket edition players on iOS and
Android phones and tablets have the
ability to plug in a controller on
compatible devices and record and share
gameplay with Windows 10 built-in game
DVR the beta launches on July 29 and
don't worry this version won't be
replacing the existing PC version of the
game be sure to stay tuned to gamespot
we will keep you updated on all upcoming
minecraft ii goodness